welcome my name is john norton and i'm
co-founder of phase 3 lab solutions
a company that provides products and
professional service to cannabis labs
today i'm going to talk about quality as
a strategic
business plan and operational model and
how a focus on quality will yield
profitable results the cannabis industry
is exciting and offers entrepreneurs an
abundance of opportunity to profit
one area that's required to ensure the
ongoing success of the industry
is in the safety and quality testing of
the cannabis based products
the regulations for cannabis vary from
state to state
however every state requires some level
of testing
entrepreneurs and vision testing is a
great opportunity
to profit from the industry where there
is an
increasing need for more testing
capacity
overall the u.s market is forecasted to
grow at an annual rate of 20 percent
considering profitability for a moment
operating expenses for a lab
with staff are estimated to be about 19
000
a week the potential revenue from a
single set of instruments is roughly
fifty three thousand dollars a week
when problems delay the lab from
generating income
the missed revenue is considered
opportunity cost
combining opera operating expenses with
missed revenue
the average cost of delay is estimated
to be 72
000 a week
at this rate the lab desperately needs
to start generating sustainable revenue
as quickly as possible unfortunately
through phase 3 lab solutions
we are seeing avoidable delays ranging
from 8 to 18 months
accumulating anywhere from 1 to 5
million dollars of lost value
so why is this the case in order to
comprehend this problem
it's important to recognize the lab's
ultimate value in the marketplace
depends on the quality accuracy and
reliability of the test results it
produces
yet in the desperate urgency to generate
income
startups unintentionally cut corners
compromise
quality and unwittingly sacrifice the
sustainable revenue they're trying to
capture
the most common approach for cannabis
lab startups in the us
is to find a location build out a
facility acquire state-of-the-art
instruments
hire consultants to validate methods get
a provisional license
patch together a quality system and then
struggle to get accredited before the
provisional license expires
the struggle is completely avoidable by
simply reconsidering
priorities and the sequence of startup
activities
although it's common for two years to
pass before cannabis lab
generates revenue it's not a two-year
process
many other labs and other industries get
started and accredited
in as little as six months with quality
as a strategic
business plan and operational model
cannabis labs can go from instrument
installation
to accreditation and sustainable revenue
generation
in six months or less avoiding millions
of lost value
this value generation and speed is only
possible with a commitment to quality
based on the tenants of iso 17025
the international standard for
laboratory competence
and with a management system that's
designed and optimized for a cannabis
lab an operational model that's
supported by a logically structured qms
ensures that the lab can deliver
predictable and sustainable results
the qms also addresses many aspects of
the business plan
as well as how the laboratory operates
and delivers accurate and reliable
results
with quality as a strategic business
plan and an
operational model every decision is made
within the context of achieving
predictability
before getting into specific solutions
it's important to identify and examine
some of the common startup mistakes when
planning and operating a cannabis lab
the first mistake is related to the
sequence of startup activities
the typical sequence begins with the
facility build out
instrument selection installation and
then hiring personnel
following these milestones labs think
that they can quickly move to validating
their methods and obtain accreditation
sounds simple enough right but as you
may know
the validation stage is the most
difficult stage of startup
in where so many labs implode
it's not that the preceding activities
are inappropriate
the fundamental problem is that the
activities are performed out of sequence
early decisions are made and milestones
are passed independent of a qms
through phase 3 lab solutions we often
see that a lab's qms is either missing
inadequate or not being followed this
leads to developing bad habits
poor record-keeping practices fragmented
documentation
illogical workflows and all-around
confusion
all of this translates into lost
productivity
frustration invalid methods and
challenging audits
a better approach would be to reconsider
the preceding decisions in the context
of an iso qms
and to resequence the startup activities
to sum it up labs can get to
accreditation
and sustainable revenue generation they
can't get there
because they can't get through
validation
standard operating procedures referred
to as sops
and validation procedures are another
area where common mistakes
occur when acquiring instruments labs
are
often convinced that the equipment comes
complete with turnkey sops
the reality is the supplied instruments
documentation
is a combination of oem marketing
materials and
application notes that provide only 30
percent of the content required
of a usable sop
while the application notes are a good
resource for reference
they do not conform with iso 1702.5
requirements for document control
and are not cross-referenced with the
qms
the application notes also omit critical
technical content
such as realistic matrix attributes
quality control procedures
instrument work lists corrective actions
and a myriad of technical details
that are required to guide a technician
through the proper execution
evaluation and reporting of analysis
results
to make matters worse when validating
methods
there's a large amount of confusion
resulting from the immaturity of the
industry
coupled with marketing ploys that
suggest an application note
is validated to the extent required by
the lab
often a lab begins with a validation and
nothing more
than an oem application note possesses
no written validation procedures
and is armed with only state dictated
performance requirements
during validation events a lot of data
is generated but there is little thought
invested into a structured design of
experiments to ensure the right data
and the right amount of data is
generated in fact some labs miss the
most fundamental step of ensuring
all equipment is calibrated and
traceable to a national standard
prior to commencing validation
activities
over-reliance on application notes
coupled with
inadequate validation procedures
ultimately yields
either sops that cannot be validated or
validation events that need to be
repeated
costing the lab precious time and
wasting consumables
and money
lastly we see startups operating on
shoestring budgets
with skeleton crews who are struggling
as they juggle multiple responsibilities
and serve as first responders to daily
surprises
this situation distracts personnel from
receiving critical training
carrying out proficiency testing
overseeing calibration activities and
building out the qms
the laboratory personnel who are closest
to the revenue generating work
are stretched so thin that they neither
develop the foundational competency
required to perform their
responsibilities
nor perform billable testing this
situation
as well as ever growing pressure to
become accredited
weighs on personnel and even causes
employee turnover further extending the
timelines
and increasing overall costs as you can
see
there are many opportunities to make
mistakes when starting up a cannabis lab
cumulatively these mistakes combined
with others
cause months of avoidable delays loss of
business revenue
and puts the lab at economic risk labs
that are lucky enough to survive this
phase
are not in the free and clear
looking forward an operational model
based on an
unstable foundation has more costly
risks ahead
cannabis labs are the most technically
difficult types of quality control labs
to open
narrowing in on cannabis testing
accurate measurements are significantly
more challenging
when considering the diversity of
chemical and microbial characteristics
of cannabis
given the state imposed acceptance
criteria
and lack of standardized methods for
cannabis each lab is left to develop
their
own expertise in circumstances such as
this
quality control measures are paramount
each step along the cannabis products
journey in the measurement process
starting with sampling transportation
sample preparation
and ending with testing can contribute
to inaccuracies
and uncertainties in the measurement
labs must fully understand all of the
variables that contribute to uncertainty
and institute adequate quality controls
to manage and minimize the risk of
inaccurate measurements
laboratories with poor and neglected
management systems
often produce inaccurate and
non-defensible test results
which affects the state holders and the
financial viability of the lab
since most required testing is designed
to ensure the safety of cannabis
products
inaccurate test results place the
consumers at serious health risk
depending on the origin of inaccuracy it
can affect
multiple analyses including foreign
matter inspection
residual solvents heavy metals
pesticides and microbials
the laboratory investors as well as
cannabis producers
are put at risk when inaccurate and
non-defensible results of analysis are
published
with no margin for error and tight
tolerances for acceptability
inaccurate analyses can conclude with a
false acceptance or a false rejection
of cannabis products
in the case of a false acceptance
potentially unsafe products are
permitted to go to market to be sold
beyond the health risk to the consumers
the labs
and growers face product recalls
substantial fines
and other penalties imposed by the state
alternatively a false rejection means
that growers potentially lose out on
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
income
as they must destroy all of the affected
product
both situations lead to undesirable
outcomes
the stakes are high and the lab's
reputation is on the line
frequent incidents of incorrect test
results will cause the lab's clients to
lose confidence in its credibility
and look elsewhere for a more reliable
service
however with appropriate quality
controls these risks can be managed and
minimized
by now it should be clear that there are
a lot of challenges and risks involved
when starting up
and operating a cannabis lab the
unanswered question is
what solutions can be implemented to
prevent the problems
and yield sustainable profitable revenue
with so much on the line a comprehensive
solution
and business strategy is needed the
solution needs to emphasize the
importance of quality and put it at the
forefront of every decision
this begins with quality as a strategic
business plan
and follows with quality as an
operational model
the next step is to recognize that
people are the most important resource
and ensure
the lab has the right people at the
right time
and to focus on building competency and
enabling
knowledge transfer finally a fully
functional iso qms
tailored to the cannabis lab is needs to
provide the framework for all activities
that occur when starting up
and operating the lab in the long run
commitment to quality is a winning
strategy
with quality as a strategic business
plan
the plan is unrelenting by placing
quality at the forefront of every
decision
and establishes a stable foundation for
every subsequent decision
practically this involves changing the
sequence of events by implementing
an iso qms in the very beginning of the
startup process
this is critically important because all
decisions must consider what is needed
to deliver accurate
and repeatable test results the
requirements for what is needed
is usually governed by state regulated
limits and client expectations
understanding needs can ensure that the
facility
environmental controls adjacent
activities
security instruments are all selected
and verified to enable the delivery of
reliable test results
the qms should be considered an input to
the business plan because it provides
25 of the content required for a
comprehensive plan
next an operational business model needs
to be created
and shared with everyone who is involved
in the decision making
or performing activities that affect
quality
this model starts with a commitment to
quality
a rest the business model rests on an
unrelenting commitment to the qms
ensuring that
everything that affects the quality of
testing is understood
and governed by the qms
this foundation supports four key
pillars of people
process infrastructure and tools and
technology
with this model the lab can generate
sustainable and profitable revenue
visualizing the operational model in
this way reveals the dependency of the
entire structure
on the management's commitment to
quality and follows with the reliance on
a well-structured carefully planned and
implemented qms
once quality is solidly established as
the foundation
and an operational qms is in place
the next step is to define the
credentials competencies and values that
are required of future laboratory
personnel
who will ultimately be responsible for
the test results
that generate sustainable and profitable
revenue for the lab
this eventuality reinforces the
principle
that people are the most valuable
resource for the lab
it follows that the requirements for
personnel need to be defined
and that the candidates are carefully
screened against the required
credentials
competencies and values the personnel
requirements are an integral
component of the qms and are identified
as competency requirements
understanding who is needed and when is
equally important
a quality manager should be considered a
high priority position
to oversee all aspects of quality during
startup mode
this is one area where professional
consultants can add temporary capacity
and independently manage the
implementation of the qms
as the labs team is feverishly working
to commence method validation
since people are most the most important
resource
priority must be placed on transferring
knowledge during
startup to enable the laboratory
personnel to function
independently of the instrument
manufacturers and consultants
when they move on to other clients the
lab's operational model
needs to include provisions to further
the development
of its personnel thereby increasing the
collective competency
and ensuring the lab can succeed in
delivering accurate and reliable results
without constant intervention of
external support
through phase three we see talented
consultants who arrive to provide method
validation services
and then depart without transferring
knowledge to the lab's team
leaving them unable to repeat the
validation and unprepared for an audit
it's important to know that iso 17025
is a competency standard for the
laboratory personnel
not the consultants hiring consultants
that don't transfer knowledge is a waste
of an invaluable opportunity to embed
competency
in the lab
now that the business plan and
operational models establish
quality as a strategic value and that
people are recognized as the most
important resource the lab needs a
construct to operate within
this is where the iso qms enters the qms
provides a written framework for the lab
to operate within
it contains all of the crucial policies
procedures work instructions
forms and records needed to ensure
consistency
while operating the lab consistency is
required to attain predictability
a key ingredient of accurate and
reliable test results
with the qms being such a foundational
component of the lab's operational model
it's important to consider proper
construction of a qms
so many labs try to pinch pennies by
developing their own
or acquiring a generic template while
these approaches offset near-term cash
flow
they require a heavy investment of time
because of the haste to patch a qms
together
it's sub-optimal fragmented and
inefficient
ultimately the short-term savings
results in a huge
long-term loss of value
an effective qms should require minimal
effort to use and maintain
it should be accessible to all
laboratory personnel
and be cross-referenced to iso 17025
state regulations and the accrediting
body's requirements
currently iso 17025 has 220 requirements
and the qms needs to fulfill all of them
and designate storage locations for the
records the lab produces
accrediting bodies who assess the labs
are often more lenient in the beginning
when labs are starting
but become much more stringent stringent
as the lab matures
the key point is to understand that the
qms should comprehend both the near-term
and long-term needs it should be in
continuous use
and undergoing continuous improvement as
the lab matures
here's a question does a qms actually
provide a return on investment
consider this a lab invests a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars for an
instrument
that contributes to ten percent of its
revenue
the instrument requires ongoing
maintenance calibration
and has a finite life in contrast
the management system supports 100
percent of the lab's revenue
and provides the long-term foundation
for how a lab will operate
and ultimately succeed both the
instrument
and the qms require high degree of
technical competency
to start up and operate yet the
weighting
of the instrument investment is
disproportionately
out of balance with the investment in
the qms
it almost seems absurd that investors
are willing to compromise the very
most foundational component of starting
up and operating a cannabis lab
neglecting to account for a qms is
costly but it doesn't need to be this
way
a hundred and fifty thousand dollar
investment in a qms and professional
support can completely flip the curve
from a cost of delay
to a positive return on on investment
delivering up to 2.7 million dollars of
value in the first 18 months
so where does all of this lead
clearly cannabis labs have a lot of
economic potential
and can be profitable investments the
number one reason they struggle to start
up and remain profitable
is because of an incorrect mindset that
loses sight of the ultimate value of its
services
most people consider a qms to be a
necessary evil of running a lab
and either try to avoid it or treat it
as another thing to do
however the mindset mindset needs to
shift to one that emphasizes the qms
as the way to work and by doing so
the lab will produce profitable results
beginning with the end in sight
meaning focusing on the predictability
accuracy
reliability and timeliness of test
results will ensure the laboratory
personnel and investors are always
working in the same direction
as such the qms sops and validation
protocols
should be considered just as important
as if not more important
than investments in instruments and
other physical assets required to
operate the lab
the laboratory personnel who ultimately
perform the billable work
should be considered the most important
resources of the lab
the lab must get the best people who are
competent and naturally committed to
quality
laboratory personnel should be provided
with training
and time to develop deeper competencies
in
all aspects of the work they perform as
well as with the qms
so is it too late if you've already
started
or have been operating a cannabis lab
without quality as a strategic
plan and an operational model
absolutely not it's never too late
to renew your commitment to quality and
convert to a robust management system
quality is the inevitable strategic plan
and operational model
labs that embrace this will have a
profitable business
for years to come thank you for your
time and attention today